Hi, I'm Don Dini.
I'm a principle data scientist at AT&T.
As a data scientist it is my job to build models.
My background is in artificial intelligence and computer science.
Now among other things today, I work on using simulation to
solve problems that are often too hard for traditional analytical approaches.
Such as understanding city populations, and
the design of communication networks.
I will appear mostly in lesson One and
lesson Two to guide you through the first half of the class.
>> Hi, my name is Rishi Raj Prabahan,
I'm also a principle data scientist at AT&T.
My background is in experimental high energy physics.
As part of the team that built the Atlas Detector that ended up discovering
the Higgs Particle, completing the standard model of particle physics.
A model that in a single mathematical equation,
describes the behavior of all known matter and their interactions.
I will follow up, after Don, and appear in the second half of the course.
We are both working on various problems effecting networks,
systems, data and customers of AT&T.
In this course, we will try to introduce you
to as much of the formal mathematics, statistics, machine learning and
programming as the everyday experience of data analysis and model building.